this video is sponsored by North Vee P n
take a listen to this scene Street
you're born a street rat you'll die a
street rat and all the fries will more
you I know this one
it sort of hits your ears wrong right
like there's something missing now
listen to this one
you cannot just break into a palace and
walk around like you own the place if
you don't have anything you have to act
like you own everything I think this one
works better I think this is why the
live-action Aladdin works better as a
film than the live-action Lion King did
at least for me it's the difference
between adaptation and recreation to
adopt a work is not the same as
recreating a work when we attempt to
recreate something it's very easy to
fall flat because while it's on-screen
we are always going to judge its success
based on what it's trying to do which is
to faithfully retell the original story
in an attempt to achieve the same
emotions in all of us adaptation on the
other hand utilizes various aspects of
the original property to create a
different experience think frozen in the
ice queen or Aladdin in the book Arabian
Nights these stories are based off of
old tales there are adaptations but they
also have their own identity in the case
of the live-action Aladdin film it keeps
certain things the same and many other
things different however unlike the 90s
animated film the live-action take isn't
basing its story off of a book that was
told hundreds of years ago it is dead
trying to modernize something we are all
familiar with and as a result when you
see this you're comparing it to this and
when you hear this you're listening for
this
you are a worthless street rat it's
because of this film studios working on
these remakes typically tried to create
their own version of the story where
possible staying close enough to the
original to draw people in and far
enough away to bring something new to
the table when a remake is almost a
shot-for-shot recreation it's asking to
be compared with the original when a
remake builds a new story out of the
original material it develops its own
identity and Aladdin succeeded in that
effort
I believe the characters personalities
are slightly altered or entirely
different the story is similar but takes
an entirely different path and it even
has some of its own unique musical
numbers the live-action Aladdin film
because it wasn't married to the
material of the original it was free to
explore new possibilities and therefore
enjoy moments where it was its own thing
and while it definitely had interesting
moments that led many to negatively
compare it to the original it at the
very least tried to offer something new
the live-action Lion King however for
the most part didn't it tried to keep as
many things the same as possible while
changing very little demonstrating what
looks like a time shot-for-shot
recreation of the original as the scenes
progressed on by the film did add some
interesting scenes not found in the
animated version that offered greater
context surrounding Nala and the
lionesses during their time on her scar
but where my biggest issue lies with the
film is with its smallest change
something I believe fundamentally breaks
the film and makes it much less
effective overall and a came during this
scene
[Music]
believe it or not this was the single
most important scene in the film for
Simba and I'll explain why as Nala
begins to trip and slide down the side
of the slope instead of continuing to
run away Simba runs back and claws one
of the hyenas in the face this was a
vital characterization for Simba for it
demonstrates that despite being stubborn
and childish he is genuinely brave and
cares deeply for knowledge safety
willing to put himself in danger to
protect her the live-action film
includes the chase scene but entirely
removes Nonna's fall and Simba's brave
save resulting in a much less endearing
symbol Erik tur for the life of me I
can't understand why terrific character
moments like this were removed that
ultimately only served to do one thing
make Simba less likable every main
character needs their moment to show
that they are not just all talk that if
they truly believe what they do they
must demonstrate that eren yeager an
attack on titan had it an episode one
while trying to lift the roof off of his
mother Ash Ketchum had it in the very
first episode of Pokemon when he stood
to defend Pikachu who had be nothing but
mean to him since meeting him even the
live-action Aladdin film did it too
because they knew that we need a reason
to believe in her main character and
unfortunately the Lion King misses that
mark entirely Simba never proved himself
to be anything other than a petulant
child which is a massive shame because
the story is about Simba it's not about
Nala
it's not about Mufasa even it's the
story of Simba and if your main
character doesn't communicate why we
should root for him effectively then it
falls flat imagine if we went to the
original Aladdin and removed the scene
where after tremendous effort he gives
the food he needs to the orphans if we
took that away suddenly Aladdin becomes
much less likable because first
impressions matter what a character does
is what makes them interesting skier's
scheming Hercules is heroism bell's
kindness these are all attributes that
need to be shown to us in order to make
the character what the director wants
them to be for instance and how to train
your dragon hiccups father is a revenge
obsessed angry Viking his anger and
resentment towards the Dragons leads him
and his men to grave danger
however despite being narrow-minded and
stubborn hiccups father is still will
to give up his own life in order to buy
time for his men to retreat this does
not contradict anything about his
character and instead sheds light on it
if not for this scene if not for this
decision
hiccups father wouldn't be nearly as
likeable and thus would struggle to be
redeemed later in the film in the case
of the Lion King I was utterly floored
when I saw the elephant graveyard scene
play out I had absolutely no idea why I
or anyone in the story would even like
Simba why Rafiq he had an interest in
seeing him be king or why Nala ever
cared about him enough to build a loving
relationship this is the issue I have
with how the live-action Lion King was
written and more broadly this is a
symptom of what I think is the issue
with trying to retell these stories if
you keep things so tight to the original
it can't breathe on its own then any
minor change that's added is at a much
greater risk of being scrutinized and
creating a ripple effect that ruins the
entire character or at worst the entire
story but Before we jump ahead to that I
want to quickly thank today's sponsor
Nord VPN article 13 has passed in Europe
which means the internet freedoms of
millions of people have been put at risk
but thankfully Nord VPN has given me
peace of mind if you follow the link in
the description north VPN com4 slash
totally nut mark and use coupon code
holding up mark you can get 75% off and
protect yourself for three years while
getting an extra month for free don't
let article 13 or net neutrality dictate
what you can do online protect yourself
with Nord VPNs military-grade encryption
enable it on your Android and iOS
devices and my personal favorite never
worry about region locks again go to
Nord VPN comm /join up mark and use
coupon code tone up mark to protect
yourself online today up until now I've
been singing the praises of Aladdin but
it's by no means the perfect film and
unsurprisingly its shortcomings surface
when it tries to stick close to the
original material so let's look at this
clip one more time and try to figure out
why it doesn't translate effectively
without the exaggerated caricatures
certain characters were drawn to be in
these lines of dialogue are much less
believable when delivered by a live
action actor with the animation a
viewers
spen of disbelief is far more forgiving
than when it's setting is reality when
we see aladdin and Jasmine talking atop
a roof overlooking what looks like a
demonstration in China after a short
carpet ride it doesn't take us out of
the story whereas if the visuals of the
live action break the rules of reality
it becomes much more noticeable and
sometimes jarring this is largely the
reason why Jeannie looked off to so many
people when it's surfaced online in
animation you can afford to be
over-the-top with character acting to
enhance the dialogue but in live action
you need to consider how the dialogue
will be received by the viewer much more
often with that said however there are
tons of interesting changes that work
surprisingly well most of the new scene
additions are welcome and really added
something new to the story in particular
Aladdin's pickpocketing which while
present in the original has been used to
what I think greater effect in this
during certain new scenes this works
specifically well because it's a
technique that exists in reality and
therefore is more oppressive when done
in real life even the genie which I
would argue is up there as one of the
most difficult to cast for was done much
better than I anticipated upon first
viewing in the parts where the script
deviates from the original we are able
to see Will Smith put his own spin on
the character like this this is a big
act no that is not a big head
I thought that was pretty funny it's
also a great example of a joke that
works better in live-action than it
would in animation the ridiculousness of
the Hat is obviously a call back to the
prior scene but it also stands in
absurdist contrast with the realistic
environment and characters around him
I'm not suggesting that this version of
the genie or that this film is superior
to the animated one that's entirely
subjective I'm simply pointing out that
this particular direction they took the
film in has served the movie better than
if they had done a one-to-one recreation
like The Lion King attempted to the
live-action Aladdin isn't perfect in
fact I wish it had leaned more into
doing its own thing more often the film
suffered scrutiny when it tried to
recapture the original material and was
surprisingly competent when navigating
its own path so how would I describe
Disney's live-action Aladdin clumsy 13:8
charming sort of The Lion King was a
full blown recreation with some
sprinkles of change Aladdin was an
adaptation that tried to stay close to
the original the strongest parts from
both of these films apart from The Lion
King Canute Simba's defining moment was
the change they brought to the story
which gives me high hopes for this film
when it was announced at the new
live-action Mulan wasn't going to
feature Mu Shu the dragon PI like many
others was no god but honestly after
going back to rewatch the original Mulan
film I don't think this is a terrible
decision now this is an entirely
subjective take but I'll try to explain
my reasoning while the lion king and
alladin all had humorous sidekick
characters the stories also had huge
elements of humor and fun sprinkled in
before those comedic characters were
introduced in other words they were
consistent with the tone of the story
Aladdin was already funny before the
genie and so was Simba the tale of Mulan
on the other hand however is a tragic
troubled war-torn path a young girl
takes to save her father from certain
death and honestly I think whenever moo
shu showed up he was totally at odds
with the film's themes remove him and
the film is a very serious and fantastic
war story removed the genie or Timon and
Pumbaa from those films and you still
have large amounts of humor through
their main characters and supporting
characters but that's not even the main
reason I am hopeful for the new
live-action to film in the original moo
shu was the catalyst for every single
major event in the film who was
responsible for the troops going on the
move Vishu who was responsible for
drawing attention of the Huns in the
snowy mountains no shoe and that one was
entirely by accident which injects
randomness into your story and can be
argued was a moment of deus ex machina
writing but my point is now that moo shu
isn't part of the story it frees up the
entire plot to take a different approach
and that's exciting going by the trailer
it looks like a very different story -
and I hope it is to be clear I don't
hate Mu Shu or even dislike him
in fact Mulan was my favorite Disney
movie for a very long time while I was
growing up and I had nothing against the
Mulan film having a comedic touch to it
I mean that's why all of her friends in
the Army were there in the first place
but if they are going to reimagine these
classic films I want to see something
new because these are films that we've
all grown up with films that have helped
sculpt who we are in many ways and
nothing is going to replace the Lion
King Aladdin or even Mulan for me that
is why I want to see Disney create
instead of recreate we are at a point
now where every live-action remake
will be met with intense scrutiny for
being too similar or for changing too
much but scrutiny and pressure isn't
always a bad thing
and if mulan has taught me anything it's
that the flower that blooms in adversity
is the most rare and beautiful of all
thanks for watching
[Music]